c'est une grande première pour une
commune des yvelines ce mardi 18 janvier
carrières sous poissy a reçu le label
villes engagées contre le sida cette
distinction remise par l'association
élus locaux contre le sida pour but
d'accompagner la politique de la ville
sur le vih ce sont des politiques
publiques qui vont être déclinés sur le
champ des ressources humaines sur le
champ de la prévention sur le champ de
l'éducation sur le champ 2
secteur des affaires périscolaires mais
c'est aussi et surtout un
concrètement un engagement de
l'administration communale de porter une
politique de santé publique de lutte
contre le sida ce label a été créé en
2011 avec une idée à l'époque rendre
plus visible la lutte des collectivités
contre le vih chaque commune peut
demander ce label le dossier est ensuite
examiné par l'association si on ne parle
pas du vih et bien carrières sous poissy
comme ailleurs beaucoup de gens vivent
avec ce virus est souvent sont dans une
espèce de honte n'osent pas le dire et
donc c'est important que cette ville
disent 'vous savez nous on est là on
vous accueille on est à vos côtés il
faut pas se battre contre les personnes
qui vivent avec le vih il faut se battre
contre contre se contre ce virus et donc
le message de deux carrières sous poissy
est extrêmement importante à carrières
sous poissy ce label sera présent
visuellement en entrée on sentit l'huile
sur des panneaux